Pourquoi ces trucs existent ? Les amis aujourd'hui,
ça va pas du tout. Il faut que je vous parle d'une phobie que j'ai depuis que je suis tout petit.
Certains ont la phobie des vers, d'autres ont la phobie des serpents.
Ah, j'en vois deux trois qui ont eu des petits frissons là.
Moi j'ai peur des p***** d'araignées de m**** !
Je suis hyper violent avec elles mais putain je les respecte pas du tout!
Un être possédant plusieurs pattes, aux courbes démoniaques
et aux poils plus nombreux que les cheveux d'un adulte de 50 ans.
Elle possède plusieurs yeux
mais aussi deux crochets
pour bien t'enc*ler si jamais tu l'énerves ! Eheheh...
On va parler tous ensemble des araignées, dans quel but ?
Dans le but de battre ma p***** de phobie!
Peut-être la vôtre du coup.
On sait pas !
Il y a aucun meilleur truc à faire pour combattre sa phobie que d'y faire face !
C'est beau ce que je dis bordel !
Alors il y a plusieurs araignées qui sont très connues parce qu'elles sont particulièrement dangereuses.
Il y a l'araignée violoniste.
Déjà juste son nom elle fait extrêmement peur.
On dirait qu'elle t'endort avec son violon pour mieux te manger, c'est incroyable !
Elle a des grandes pattes !
Immenses !
Ce qui est bien avec cette araignée c'est, qu'en plus d'être extrêmement dégueulasse,
le venin va attaquer tes artères,donc ce qui te maintient en vie finalement,
et tes vaisseaux, donc ta peau, va pourrir littéralement
Mec, juste en disant ça je suis pas bien !
Donc celle-là c'est une bosse grosse bâtarde qui va te mettre mal.
Rassurez-vous, généralement t'en rencontres aux Etats-Unis et pas en Europe.
Donc on est plutôt bien.
La Tegenaria domestica.
Aaaaah !
Ah, ça met vraiment pas bien bordel !
Ça c'est l'araignée que j'avais rencontré dans une vidéo il y a deux ans.
"Non mais à chaque fois je mais av...
Oh il y a une araignée énorme dans ma chambre sa mère !!!
AAAAAH !
What the fuck ???"
Ça avait très mal terminé pour elle,
alors qu'en vrai j'aurais pas du tout dû la buter avec un produit.
J'aurai juste dû la prendre et la foutre dehors !
Mais j'avais pas le courage, vraiment !
Et même maintenant mec si j'ai pas un verre à proximité je panique!
Là j'ai un tasse, une tasse razer.
A quoi elle  sert cette tasse razer ?
Elle sert uniquement à capturer une araignée en-dessous si j'en vois une.
Et à la foutre dehors.
"Les mâles font six à neuf millimètres,
les femelles 7 à 11."
C'est assez petit !
Ça vit pas très longtemps !
"Une femelle peut vivre 5 ans".
Pardon ?
Quoi ?
Quand t'en as une chez toi elle peut être là cinq années mon pote !
T'as plus de chance de quitter l'appartement avant elle mon gars !
En vrai je comprends totalement que des gens puissent adorer les araignées, vraiment !
D'ailleurs j'en avais croisé un.
Une fois dans ma vie c'est arrivé en 20 ans.
Et ça à très mal fini mec !
On est en colonie de motocross comme ça, on s'amuse.
Ouais j'ai fait une colonie de motocross quand j'étais plus jeune ouais !
Sur des Piwis.
Des Piwis 50.
Ou des 80 pour ceux qui avaient des bibis.
Donc dans ce genre de colo déjà les douches tu sais c'est un peu ghetto, tu vois.
Il y a souvent les fenêtres ouvertes et il y a beaucoup d'araignées au-dessus.
A un moment y'a une araignée qui tombe dans la douche,
donc on se douchait tous en maillot,
et le mec il se jette dessus !
Il fait : "Non ! La tuez pas ! C'est mon amoureuse!"
Ok !
Un matin, on fait de la Piwi comme ça, on est bien
et je vois tous mes potes qui se regroupent à un endroit.
Je fais : "Mais qu'est ce qu'il se passe dis donc?"
J'y vais et le mec avait trouvé une araignée noire avec des tâches jaunes !
Elle était tigrée comme les moustiques tigres mais sur une araignée.
Et on sait très bien que tout ce qui est tigré,
généralement il faut vraiment courir,
loin,
à l'opposé !
Il choppe l'araignée comme ça
et ensuite il se fait un kiff, il met sa main sous la tasse comme ça.
Et il fait : "Regardez ! Il y a une araignée ! Incroyable !"
Elle l'a mordu avec ses deux crochets.
Il a fini à l'hôpital.
Voilà ! C'est peut ête pour ça que je suis traumatisé des araignées.
Ouais c'était ça, c'était ça, c'était ça !
"Argiope frelon"
biologie.. elle pique ou pas? dites que juste ça! (il lit :) Tous les spécialistes décrivent comme une espèce inoffensive cela signifie qu'elle
n'a aucune chance de vous mordre
Pourquoi il est allé à l'hôpital alors?Ou alors jsuis un mythomane et tout ça n'est jamais arrivé ?...
OH! Apparemment il se peut que ce soit une épeire frelon et là c'est beaucoup plus grave c'est une araignée VENERE. Alors est ce que
celle là elle fait mal parce que je sais qu'il est allé à l'hôpital le mec je vous ment pas "Après l'accouplement le mal est souvent
tué puis mangé par la femelle" donc déjà on sait que c'est gentil (ixde)
"Son venin peut nous causer des soucis s'il s'avère que la personne piquée est allergique à son venin" bah écoutez
bas il était peut-être allergique alors tout simplement parce que moi je me souviens qu'il était très rouge et que ça lui grattait beaucoup
il avait décidé de l'emmener à l'hôpital donc ça devait être sa bon
continuons connaissez-vous la veuve noire une très bonne araignée celle là elle est incroyable la veuve noire vous la connaissez sûrement c'est une araignée noire avec du rouge
sur son corps elle est extrêmement
vénéneuse son venin est une petite saloperie qui contient de la latrotoxine. Ce venin est 15 fois plus puissant que le venin
du serpent à sonnettes c'est à dire que cette toxine à elle va faire que tu va produire énormément de
neurotransmetteurs et les conséquences de sa sont multiples dues à avoir de la fièvre des sueurs froides de la pression artérielle
tu peux carrément avoir des hallucinations
être anxieux avoir peur de mourir enfin ça c'est du délire s'agit complètement sur ton putain cerveau mais elle te tue pas tout va bien
Elle te tue pas! Non mais mec est tellement vénère qu'elle capture
un serpent n'y a plus aucune limite avec cette araignée
il est tellement baiser il peut rien faire
ne rien faire elle l'a québlo (bloqué) dedans mais mecs tu te rends compte à quel point une toile c'est solide?! Un truc qui sort d'un
si petit truc c'est dingue ce qui est terrifiant avec la veuve noire c'est qu'elle est extrêmement
dangereuse et qu'elle est extrêmement petite. Elle fait et 15 mm.Y'a vraiment une expression qui me rend ouf c'est quand tu es un dîner que tu
as peur jsais pas d'une guêpe et qui y'a ton grand-père qui te dit "Mais c'est pas la petite bête qui va manger la grosse!"
C'est vraiment la pire expression c'est pas parce que c'est petit que ça va pas te démolir quoi XD la morale
est nulle ! Regarde, moi mec, je fais 1.70  mais les mecs d'1.90 il se méfie de ouf de moins ils savent que
je suis........ *malaise*
ON PASSE A AUTRE CHOSE.
Alors là je vous parle d'araignées méga hardcore
mais en vrai juste l'araignée de base je ne connais pas son nom mais c'est celle où les pâtes sont
extrêmement fine et son corps c'est juste un point un tout petit point. Jsais c'que c'est cette araignée
ya dans tous les foyers du monde juste salle elle me met pas bien mener à bien l oms est passée une poussière d'un tee
shirt du sénat renier sa gay phurba c'est celle là regardez on la connaît bien voilà c'est vraiment ça
sauf que là il joue ma mort en vrai c'est vraiment minuscule quoi c'est un folk ça s'appelle voilà elle craint le froid
elle peut pas survivre en dehors de nos habitations c'est pour ça qu'on les trouve tout le temps dans nos maisons la présence de cette
araignée dans nos foyers très bénéfique pour l'homme car malgré sa taille elle ne craint aucun insecte ni même les autres araignées qu'elle n'hésite d'ailleurs
pas à attaquer durant les mois ou les proies se font rares on a même constaté qu'elles tuent et des araignées dangereuse pour l'homme comme
la tg narnia agrestis sculpteur c'est cette année là qu'est le mec avait sauvé dans la douche à l'époque oui vous ai dit qu'on était
emmailloté pas
ok le mec est un faux mais parce qu'à l'époque il m'avait expliqué ça justement fm élèves et les mecs ces derniers sont trop gentils
elles font elles sont trop bénéfique pour nous elles tuent les moustiques et autres insectes qui passent par là mais elles vont jamais vous attaquer
donc prenez les couach avait pas alors on va passer à l'araignée suivante mais une petite info cool
rappelons que les araignées ne voit rien à plus de 2
cm
vous savez je savais pas du tout tu vois ce genre d'info ça fait plaisir c'est à dire que quand leurs aînés elle est là
et que tu fais ça te voit pas donc techniquement tu es pas mal la grande majorité des cas de morsures sont causés par la
présence de ces araignées dans des vêtements laissé à terre dans des chaussures ou dans des lits dont les draps sont restés à terre trop
longtemps les personnes qui ont fui ces textiles ou ses chaussures coince l'araignée qui paniquent et ce même ordre au quelle
horreur oh putain j'ai misé plus partait en plus
dit que sa mère tuée en pleine paranoïa mondiale la plus incroyable des araignées vous en avez sûrement entendu parler pourquoi l incroyable parce que
déjà elle te démonte un la
tarentule géante du sri-lanka j'en ai pas entendu ben tarentule on connaît tarentule géante votre façon j'ai rarement une tarentule ces géants comme tu t'imagines
à quoi il ressemble en la pute elle se fond dans la masse
allez balin franchement elle est mal j'avoue elle est belle elle est colorée et où on
dirait on a envie de la voir pour noël tu sais enfin pendant deux minutes un scorpion est l'attaqué un scorpion le
professeur des voyages quand il ya des gens aussi qu'on perd des scorpions mais finalement est-ce campion c'est un mix entre un crabe une araignée
pour moi oh putain il est mort oh putain le suspense il est morte
Elle va y aller d'un coup
Oh
Putain en
tout cas elle est immense
donc on peut monter sur elle et s'en servir comme monture c'est incroyable à ya une veuve noire en europe tient lé présent la plupart
du temps en europe surtout autour du bassin méditerranéen
les von arx mozart n'est dangereuse car leur venin attaque le système nerveux bah oui ces petites saloperies enfin bon mec
clairement tu vois une araignée noire avec un q aussi énorme et des points rouges sur douze parties au moment où tu peux jouer au
touriste heures sur son dos il ya un bon problème l'araignée chameau qu'est ce que c'est que ça à la
saloperie haut mais qu'est ce que c'est que cette créature du des manques ses impressionnantes qu'elles y sert
véritable tronçonneuse sont capable de broyer la carapace d'un scorpion
mais c'est la terminaison qu'hollande de cp vips alpes qui constitue l' arme la plus redoutable dépourvue de poils
il se colle à la proie pour l'attraper et ne plus la lâcher
Olalala à
la déception de 713
incroyable il s'est accroché
dans mes mecs il ya vraiment des animaux qu'on était design et pour niquer la mère d autres quoi c'est vraiment ou l'araignée des sables
alors elle c'est une petite pute je connais pourquoi puisque a beaucoup de sable chez moi c'est faux j'habite à paris
elle se plante dans le sable avant de te démolir c'est fou mais qu'elle tremble à pour bien foutre ses pattes dans le sable et
elle se cache la
saloperie elle par exemple lé père venimeuse mais elle et elle n'est pas agressive avant que tu marches dessus 120 exprès puisqu'elle est planqué dans
le sable tu risques pas de te l'apprendre
vient ensuite la renier loup chinoise celle elle a fait un peu le but sur internet parce que quand elle fait des petits en fait
t'es les stocks de son abdomen et quand tu l'écrasent alors que senna manque à canet petit bail à un milliard de petites arnaques et
sordel en fait voilà elle transporte tous ces petits sur son dos et 5 et au fait qu'elle ait pas grande mais putain regarde toutes
les boutiques ya sur son dos laissez moi vous présenter
l'araignée pense ça va nous faire du bien dans cette unité avec des araignées si violente qui peuvent te guérit mais un membre de ton
corps en picore
araignée port déjà havrais tous que lanvin ça fait plaisir d'avoir une araignée coloré car peu de style
finalement vraiment elle est trop belle elle est plus à la mode que nous plus mal parade en exhibant les motifs colorés de son corps
pour tenter de gagner les faveurs de la femelle
Aussi
c'est la preuve que je trouve une araignée minium c'est trop beau mec c'est vraiment un putain de
bongwha version araignée c'est incroyable et si elle le beauf non
le po vit dedans c'est tout elle le trac terrible ça marche pas du tout sa danse
Malgré tout elle le tue après l'accouplement
Fort le mec il a fait une danse de 20 minutes il s'est fait chier il a tout donné il était comme ça elle le
beauf putain les amis il est temps de conclure cette vidéo sur les arachnides je suis content parce qu'en vrai ça m'a vraiment aidé à
mieux comprendre pourquoi j'ai la peur des araignées et à mieux assumer déjà cette peur des araignées
nous vient de la mémoire
génétique cross appel c'est ce que nous ont transmis
nos ancêtres après qu'ils aient appris qu'une araignée c'est vilain c'est des réflexes et un instinct qu'on a gardé qui datent de millions d'années que
l'époque des hommes des cavernes où ils avaient raison d'avoir peur des araignées parce que ça pouvait vraiment les flingues et donc si tu avais
pas peur des araignées et que tu voulais pas d'ag hasard année
elle demandait et tu crevé et surtout qu'à l'époque y avait pas la médecine que ya maintenant finalement c'est un héritage de nos ancêtres qui
sont morts à cause d'une araignée et il nous aide à survivre dans ce monde de brutes
je pense pas que c'est un traumatisme qui vient l'enfance ou l'adolescence
perso j'ai vu que très peu d'araignée dans ma vie elles n'ont jamais attaqué je me suis jamais fatigué par une araignée de là pourquoi
j'aurais la phobie d'un truc qui m'a jamais attaqué c'est bizarre je pensais que c'était parce que je les comprenais pas mais ça peut pas
que venir de là je les comprends toujours pas parfaitement je comprends mieux après cette vidéo mais j'en aurais encore peur mais au-delà de ça
au-delà de ça même si on a encore peur ce qu'il faut retenir c'est qu'une araignée
elle voit pas plus de 2 cm à partir de là tu es bien
après ça se passait vraiment vrai mais bon voilà je pense qu'on a très très peur alors qu en fait y'a pas tant de raisons
de ce fichier de sujets parce qu'en france il ya normalement pas d'araignée aussi
dangereuse que la venant et que la violoniste celle qu'on a vue puisque c'est pas sa région natale du tout ensuite une araignée est la
même pas conscience qu'elle est sur un être vivant fait pour réalité totalement
énorme elle a même pas de raison de mordelles pourra même pas de bouffée derrière ça sert à rien sauf si elle se sent en
danger en bas moi j'avais envie de parler des années avec vous servant une phobie et depuis je suis tout jeune et vraiment ça me
rend mal quand il a régné je suis pas bien même si elle est très petite quoi à présent je les comprends mieux donc j'aurai
moins peur donc je pourrais je pourrais aussi du comment débarrasser sans avoir à les tuer ce qui est vraiment nul
amy arachnophobes j'espère que tout comme moi vous allez mieux
je suis patient mais j'espère je veux dire le retour d'une prochaine vidéo j'espère quand même ça vous aura aidé sur un
technophobes succès avec nos filets bien
apprenez nous des choses basiques dites nous dans les commentaires des trucs moi je suis chaud ça va m'aider c'est hyper cool je vous dis
à bientôt une prochaine vidéo portez vous bien
ça !